bueno buenas tardes a todos
hoy quería comenzar un poco esta charla
este diálogo que quiero tener con
ustedes con una pregunta que básicamente
es una pregunta que me hice hace muchos
años cuando comenzaba mi camino en el
arte y en esto de comenzar a caminar y
proyectar a cumplir mis sueños que se
trata sobre cuál es la consecuencia o
cuáles son las consecuencias que pueden
traer enfrentar tus miedos
hace muchos años comencé a debatir me
esto ya preguntarme si el miedo en
realidad era un enemigo o era un aliado
y la conclusión a la que llegué a medida
que fui caminando fue que el miedo para
mí es un gran aliado y a diferencia de
lo que muchos piensan el miedo se
construye y el miedo hace que puedas
romper barreras todos tenemos miedo
supongo no todos saben lo que es la
sensación de caminar con el miedo al
dado no pero quiero que hoy comencemos a
verlo como un aliado todos podemos tener
miedo la oscuridad a nadar en el mar a
lo que dirán a lo que pueden llegar a
pensar un familiar un amigo en fin
podemos estar horas debatiendo sobre la
cantidad de miedos que transitamos a lo
largo de nuestra vida la idea es que hoy
nos vayamos con un cambio de
pensamientos sobre el miedo porque el
miedo no es un limitante es todo lo
contrario el miedo es un faro
es una guía es como una lucecita que
aparece en el momento en que tenemos que
tomar las decisiones más importantes
para nuestra vida para nuestra
supervivencia
y empezar a tomar al miedo como un
aliado como alguien que nos avisa por
dónde es el camino a seguir es es un
gran momento en el que la sensación
luego de eso es liberación y bienestar y
muchas veces los miedos son propios
también son colectivos y la liberación
de uno siempre siempre va a ser una
amenaza para todos aquellos que aún son
esclavos no estar jugando el juego que
todo el mundo está jugando va a ser
profundamente preocupante para todos
aquellos que todavía lo están haciendo
porque vienen en nosotros reflejado sus
miedos
hoy quiero contarles un poco mi proceso
del otro lado
a los 15 años decidí cambiar
rotundamente mi vida y con el apoyo de
mi familia su gran apoyo empecé un viaje
a buscar oportunidades artísticas en la
ciudad de buenos aires si tenía 15 años
y con muchísimo miedo yo y toda mi
familia me apoyaron a hacerlo hubo una
oportunidad y la tomé
y este es el quid de la cuestión cuando
identificamos el miedo como una
oportunidad y la tomamos
y lo único que tomamos en ese momento es
la decisión que la decisión es el primer
paso para enfrentar y empezar a
transitar estar del otro lado de tus
miedos donde todo lo que queremos está
ahí me presenté a una audición en la que
se presentaron más de 10.500 personas
hice más de 20 cuadras de cola
era enorme la cantidad de gente que
había
durante el proceso de la cola no tuve
miedo estaba sumamente enfocado en
tratar
de una sola cosa hacer
que me lograran ver porque era imposible
que en diez minutos pudieran ver a 300
personas entrábamos de a grupos de 300
personas y era imposible entonces ahí
fue con científica identifique el primer
miedo que haber hecho todo un viaje
haber puesto a mi familia en un gasto en
una ilusión para que ni siquiera me
logren ver
inmediatamente llegué a una conclusión
natural que fue ponerme primero era la
única forma que me dieran así que así lo
hice fui hacia adelante del todo me puse
funciona una música donde había que
improvisar y ahí estaba en frente mío pp
si dirían que seguramente muchos lo
conocen un gran director y puestista de
la argentina él frenó la música y me
miró y me preguntó qué edad tenía 18
mentí
había mentido mi edad para poder
ingresar al casting y la verdad es que
no me enorgullece hacerlo pero soy de
los que cree que la edad no es un
limitante para poder llegar a lograr lo
que uno quiere
me dijo seguro eso elige si 18
totalmente convencido
me dijo tráeme el dni y le dije por
supuesto me freno en seco y me dijo está
bien seguido audicionando
el día paso y tuve más de seis horas de
castings pasé más de 18 grupos de 300
personas y yo seguía quedando y seguía
quedando y seguía quedando terminó el
día y quedé sin saber que me restaban
ocho meses más de audición y que todos
los días iba a tener que pasar por el
mismo proceso yo contento salí
esperando a mi familia que me estaban
esperando afuera y les conté la gran
noticia claro era una gran noticia para
mí no para ellos no porque no me
apoyaran sino porque los invadió el
miedo que iba a ser un chico solo a los
15 años en capital federal nosotros no
tenemos familia no teníamos ni siquiera
los recursos posibles para que yo me
pueda quedar ahí era un gran esfuerzo
para tapar a todos pero el miedo más
grande de mis padres en ese momento era
que pasaba así después de ocho meses la
respuesta era no
así que ese día volvimos yo volví
totalmente destrozado con el corazón
roto volvimos a casa necochea llorando
todo el viaje y recuerdo que esa noche
escuché a mis papás discutir toda la
noche
hasta que la pregunta fue
y si vencemos nuestros miedos y si lo
apoyamos y si en realidad nuestros
miedos son nuestros y él está seguro de
lo que está haciendo y puede hacerlo así
que esta mañana mi papá me despertó
antes de irse a trabajar y me preguntó
si quería ir
a tomar nuevamente el casting a necochea
a capital federal
le dije que si entusiasmado nunca me
levanté tan rápido de la cama como este
día y mi mamá fue la encargada de
llevarme
durante el camino mi mamá me recalcó la
importancia de los valores que me habían
dado la importancia de enfrentar mis
miedos pero con la verdad debía llegar a
la audición y decir a los productores la
edad que tenía fuera cual fuera la
decisión de eso la verdad siempre iba a
ser una gran una gran herramienta para
enfrentar el miedo
por supuesto llegué
ingresé al casting mientras tanto mi ama
se recorrió toda la capital para
encontrar un lugar donde yo pudiera
vivir esperanza en que iba a seguir
quedando
y se le habla la audición para hacer
grupos pasaron las obras seguía pasando
seguía pasando y por supuesto no me
animé de ninguna manera el miedo me
había invadido y no había forma de que
yo dijera la verdad porque en mi cabeza
la verdad significaba que se me
terminara el sueño
mi mamá volvió ingresó y se cruzó con
una productora y le dijo discúlpame yo
soy la mamá de guido guido le pregunto
de la productora claro lo que no
entendía mi mamá en ese momento es que
yo era el 141 todavía no tenía un nombre
era imposible poner el nombre a 10.000
personas que pasaban todos los días por
el casting me dijo soy la mamá del chico
que tiene 15 años
la productora se atragantó en ese
momento ingresó a la audición y era
obvio que era yo me señaló y me hizo ir
hacia una pecera donde la producción
estaba trabajando y me preguntó qué edad
tenía nuevamente normalmente el miedo me
venció hoy de mentir 18 y me dijo no
seas nabo esta toma más fuera y me dijo
la la edad que tienes no me dijo nada
está un poco más enojada en la situación
y entre los productores de sí decidieron
que fuera a pepe
quien decidiera el destino mío dentro de
la audición
y fue así y recuerdo ver a un productor
acercarse mientras pp comía a decir al
oído mi verdad que lo escuché gritar que
venga inmediatamente a casa
me agarró un miedo de esos que te hacen
transpirar que es incómodo
y fui hacia app y me pregunto a vos me
mentiste a mí
no mira a los ojos y dije era el momento
que resultado fuera cual fuera
o sea con la verdad lo que me habían
enseñado mis papás y le dije que sí y a
diferencia de lo que yo creía
la verdad había ganado esa batalla el
miedo y pp me miró y me dijo si hubiera
hecho igual a tu edad
en conclusión
les cuento esto para que sepan que la
verdad fue la gran herramienta para que
yo pudiera continuar con mi sueño
y no solamente es tener una obra en
calle corriente sino que es tener siete
más y seis giras nacionales
internacionales hasta que un día el
miedo volvió a golpear mi puerta ya no
me completaba ese lugar aunque aprendí
muchísimo todo lo que pude todo lo que
más pude aprendí de luces de sonido de
vestuario de contar un cuento aprendí a
pisar a pisar un escenario a mostrarme
central público todos los días era un
miedo diferente porque el público era
diferente
y me enfrenté a pepe como hacía 5 años
nuevamente para decirle mi verdad y
decirle que necesitaba crecer que
necesitaba seguir mi camino por otro
lado al día siguiente de eso me desperté
muy tarde dormí como nunca lo había
hecho
y cuando me desperté no tenía nada para
hacer
y nuevamente un miedo nuevo había
ingresado a mi vida y ahora que correrá
el siguiente paso
recordé que una vez pp me contó
lo único que había visto en mí eran
ganas
y que con las ganas me va a comer el
mundo pero crea muy importante que los
sueños no sean solo sueños que los
sueños comiencen a convertirse en un
proyecto porque los sueños si son sólo
sueños son nada
los proyectos en cambio se calendarizan
se programan se ponen objetivos y se
llevan adelante hacía mucho tiempo que
quería contar un poco de mí así que en
ese instante me di cuenta que lo que
quería hacer era comenzar a escribir
escribir mi música y cuando comencé a
escribir mi música me volví a enfrentar
a otro miedo que ahí ya no era un
personaje ahí no me podía esconder atrás
de una careta de un personaje en una
comedia musical sino que tenía que
empezar a hablar de mí y hablar de uno a
veces da muchísimo miedo porque empiezan
a salir cosas que ni uno conoce porque
el miedo no hay que rodearlo no hay que
esquivarlo hay que enfrentarlo
lo que más me propuse fue intentar ser
útil mucho más que importante porque me
parece que ser útil es muchísimo más
importante aunque es tan importante
comencé a escribir y empecé a ir un poco
a mi pasado al niño que hay en todos
nosotros y surgió una palabra que fue
bullying y hoy quiero contarles un poco
por qué
quiero comunicar y quiero hablar sobre
el bullying y soy activista sobre este
flagelo son un flagelo social que nos
abarca a todos y que tiene que ver con
la niñez que tiene que ver con con el
principio de nuestras vidas y como eso
a todos los que los sufrimos nos marca
yo tuviera suerte de tener una familia y
una comunidad educativa que siempre me
acompañe pero hay muchos niños que no lo
tienen
yo siempre siempre estuve en contra de
lo típico los chicos juegan al fútbol y
yo organizaba
espectáculos en el patio del complejo
departamento donde vivíamos para los
vecinos
y cantaba y bailaba la canción de la
película titanic mientras que mi hermano
pasaba la gorra no lo hacíamos por
necesidad que hubiese sido válido
también sino que lo hacíamos por
diversión yo hoy me desarrollo como
artista y mi hermano hoy este empresario
y recuerdo que en esas actuaciones donde
los vecinos se juntaban y me aplaudían
escuchar a una vecina decirle a la otra
si lo hubiera su padre
lejos de incomodar me valgo estaba
seguro que él estaría orgulloso de mí
siempre lo estuvieron porque en mi mundo
ser diferente era una opción me
enseñaron desde muy chico que no somos
todos iguales que somos todos diferentes
y que desde las diferencias podemos
construir nos
las escuelas son lugares donde tenemos
que construir nos a partir de las
diferencias
pero hoy en día y desde hace mucho
tiempo son campos de batalla adentro de
las aulas aprendemos matemáticas lenguas
ciencias sociales
pero afuera en los recreos muchas veces
solía no salir porque había que aprender
a hacerse invisible a tratar de hacer
que nadie te vea
hasta que mi valentía ganaba a ese miedo
y agarrar el micrófono inmediato escolar
y usaba mi voz que era lo más importante
que yo tenía para cantarles quién era
recibir todo tipo de apodos y etiquetas
todo tipo de apodos y etiquetas y la
verdad es que nunca me quebré un hueso
de mi cuerpo pero nadie puede decirme
que no conozco ese dolor porque
un apodo no duele menos que quebrarse un
hueso
los chicos no tienen hoy herramientas
emocionales para enfrentarlas y creo que
desde el arte y la comunicación debemos
hacer mucho por eso
porque cuando un chico irrumpe nuevo en
una escuela
y todo el mundo decide no escucharlo se
transforma simplemente en un eco que
está de fondo repitiendo y repitiendo lo
que nadie escucha cuando los adultos
decimos cosas como por ejemplo son cosas
de chicos los chicos suelen ser crueles
los apodos y er en las etiquetas te
marcan
yo soy un recibido de lo logré los
apodos nunca me hirieron
claro que lo hicieran
pero toda mi vida va a ser un equilibrio
un acto de equilibrio entre entre
encontrar belleza por sobre el dolor
eso yo no quiero que le suceda a ningún
chico más y por eso invito a todos a
luchar en contra del bullying creo que
hay que empezar a pensar que el miedo es
lo que hace a todos como sociedad que
nos detengamos y no empecé y no
empecemos a indagar en los diferentes a
construirnos en las diferencias
yo quiero que hoy cuando lleguen a sus
casas o cuando tengan un tiempo
se miren al espejo y sean esta pregunta
que la pregunta es
cuáles creen que serán las consecuencias
para mí y para los demás de enfrentar
nuestros miedos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]